ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show special treat
for everybody this uh week we have a
best of patreon we're opening the vault
and taking select rants from our
patreon episodes like uh uh uh
made i want to fly a plane to the
capitol and
many other of our hits and we're doing
that because last night
we went out to dinner with rogan and i
was plied with pasta
against my will and bone marrow and
garlic bread and porterhouses and
and and and chocolate cakes and donuts
cream-filled doughnuts and i i just woke
up today and i'm like
ugh and i uh a red ash restaurant
in [ __ ] uh austin killer killer food
and i i just tossed and turned all night
because i'm i usually eat really really
healthy
and joe does not and this is a problem
and i get on him all the time about his
diet like
you gotta you gotta cut the carbs get
the sugar do the more of the but
you know you can't reason with them but
so we had a real
uh meal and a half last night so i just
can't there's not a full show in me
right now
um things are still gurgling and
whatever
so what i'm going to do is uh we're
going to open the vault and release
some of the great uh patreon stuff that
we've had and
uh where we talk about ben's upcoming
wedding
we talk about uh lots of different
things ben always selects these
rants from the patreons we haven't done
this in about a year
about a year and again you don't have to
join the pic this isn't like a come join
the page yeah yeah
it is fun um uh but
it's it's just good content to put out
there for for everybody that you like it
i mean there's there's
there's no agenda here you know what i
mean we're really not even
in the comedy game right now we're in
the vc game
um because you don't have to be a
venture capitalist
all you have to kind of be is a
schizophrenic and my mother is a
schizophrenic which means i have just a
certain amount of latent schizophrenia
which is that's that's like somebody
said to me to your damn like yeah rogan
and those guys they have money ron white
they have money but i have real money
now what real money means is my money
it's there's no
cap to it because it's in my head so
guys like ron wyatt or jeff donahue
their money's in the bank or in
investments and there's an end to it
mine there's no end because it's a
creation of my own
it's synapses firing in my head that
aren't linking up with other synapses so
i have as much money as i want to have
this is the era of fake business i go on
clubhouse everybody on clubhouse is very
successful and they spend 19 hours a day
on clubhouse telling you
all the interesting projects they're
working on they apparently don't have to
actually ever work on any of those
projects because they're
on that app uh so we're in the vc world
so it's not even we're not even
really trying to you know
do comedy anymore we're just looking to
to work with founders who are the
founders of the company i want to know
who the founders are what's the
monetization
strategy and who are the founders
where are the founders and what is their
strategy
and am i gonna put my war chest
of a zillion dollars again
in here everything's money so
you know what you're looking at that's
an nft right there that sign
that's a million dollars that sign so
what are we talking about money means
nothing
um so we're gonna do the best patriot
episode what did you think of that
restaurant last night
it was amazing it was really good i was
really impressed
i was truly impr i'm i'm i'm a little
bit of a
i know what i'm talking about and i'm
telling you right now in terms of time
food they kicked
[ __ ] ass last night and i was
shocked at how good it was i was ready
to like
say hey [ __ ] this but i was really
uh impressed by the quality of that
one woman was throwing ravioli at the
table to get rogan's attention
i thought it was antifa but it was just
a woman
who i think it's like auntie is
attacking him with carbs which is really
that's what you would do to weaken him
if you wanted to weaken him you would
you would tempt him you would throw
carbs at him but it was just a woman
that wanted to say hello
to him crazy we get recognized every now
and then but that guy is just getting
recognized all the time
you know which is crazy because i feel
like we are more successful and more
famous
yeah i've always felt that way
i thought i was doing him a favor by
going on a show but apparently it really
is the other way around when you look at
the numbers
interesting um
and yeah it was fun and ron why came in
hinchcliffe and faheem and
uh you lex lex friedman was
there sitting next to me he's a very
interesting dinner companion
he's like a brilliant child that someone
brought
to the dinner like kind of an awkward
brilliant child
like one of those children from like a i
don't know
like c.s lewis novel that just sits
there and he's like
hello he turned to me and he goes
do you think you have a serious movie in
you you guys that wallet trailer i liked
it but i didn't want the jokes
i wanted the darkness i'm like thank you
and didn't he have a bite of pasta too
yeah
these people they always talk about keto
and then
you go out with them i'm the only one
that does keto i'm the only one that
actually does it
i'm the only one who works out i'm the
only one who knows about fighting
i'm the only one who knows about
robotics everybody else is kind of like
it's just they're just spinning a yarn
just me and the weinsteins we're the
only people who know
the deal in this world so if you're
gonna listen
listen to one of us brett eric or me
you know were the three that have been
exiled from academia
because of because you told the truth so
so enjoy the best of patreon we have a
guy coming uh we have a meeting at 10
o'clock how do you feel like this will
go
it should be good i'm looking forward to
it yeah
meeting you ten o'clock
uh timbercomedy.com all the live shows
me and dan are on the road um
and uh that should be a lot of fun
getting in little skirmishes here and
there
uh and uh
it should be enjoyable for you guys to
come out and see
what we've got happening um thanks to
everyone that's bought tickets and come
to the shows we've had a great time we
had a nurse get angry at me
uh in pennsylvania when i was performing
a tent a nurse got can you imagine these
nurses
uh she she took a night off the plague
to come to a comedy show
and then she got angry at me because i
dared to make a
joke about nurses and she didn't
understand that jokes were not serious
they were absurd things that are said
uh to make fun to make fun you know
um that's a stand-up thing i think
recently talks about he's like why would
you make fun like stand up he
has a whole thing where he's like hey
you make fun it's like we're making fun
so she got angry she was sitting in the
front row with her face all stern and
she was like i'm a nurse and people are
dying
imagine imagine having a
job where you describe
the literal fundamentals of the job
as something that is completely alien to
you
i'm an air traffic controller and
there's so many planes
trying to land at once
it's it's almost like my entire job
is predicated on that fact that planes
are trying to
but can you imagine that they're the
planes
not one not a hundred i mean thousands
of these things
in the air at once trying to land
on four runway i mean
who knew who knew when i took this job
that uh planes would land who knew
we got a nurse that's uh going by people
are dying and wait
you're a nurse right
that's what you do is that what you do
i know it's sad that people are dying
and i tried to explain
that to her maybe we should throw in the
thing now
the video yeah yeah i'll put it up right
here we'll put the video up and here's
the video of what happened
a little angry i'm sorry you see i'm
very there's a couple here you seem very
yes you you seem very you were dragged
here i got it you were dragged you were
dragged a little better
you're slightly disappointed what is it
some of the language
you're a nurse
well so here's here's the question
here's the question
why aren't you at work i mean that's not
being very legitimate
okay well let me ask you when you when
you signed up to be a nurse
did you understand that at one time
people might get sick
like i understand as a comedian that
when i say things people can get mad at
me even though they're jokes i
understand
that in the same way that you would
understand people would get sick
right right
i know and it's very very sad but
there's all i'm i'm making jokes and
there's a lot of people that have been
dying there's people dying because their
businesses are closed
there's people dying because they they
can't make any money there's people
dying because they
they're suffering from drug and alcohol
addiction there's people dying because
they're alienated
from their communities there's people
dying because this government that shut
everything down is not giving them
checks
and i know that's not your fault i know
that's not your fault
but i've made fun of all of that tonight
i've made fun of all of that tonight
it's not just about you
i've made fun of everything that's
[ __ ] up that's happening truly
i made fun of everything i made fun of
everything
everything including myself i made fun
of everybody
you know and listen if i collapse up
here i want you to remember these are
jokes
so if i collapse come up here and be a
hero
but i don't want you to be offended
these are jokes you have to understand
that jokes are
to say ridiculous things so that people
can laugh at it nobody
thinks nobody's ungrateful for what
nurses do but these are jokes if they
were serious they wouldn't be funny
do you see what i mean like if i was
making serious statements no one would
laugh but because they are absurd
because they are ridiculous they are
jokes that's what it is
and i know that people don't understand
jokes anymore
people don't understand jokes but that
that's what they are they're just jokes
they're not meant to be hurtful they're
not meant to be rude
you know and i understand that you're
probably offended and there is an
internet
and you can go to it and write a lot of
mean things about the many have before
and they will again and that's okay but
i'm sorry that you're offended but these
are literally just jokes
they're just jokes okay
that's really what it is they're jokes
they're jokes you know except the part
about the nurses
i'm serious about that my name is tim
miller thank you very much everybody
thank you good morning all right so you
saw that video
and uh now enjoy the best of our
uh tim miller patreon we're back in the
studio next week where i don't even know
i might be in florida
i don't know i might have to fly you
down to florida you people don't care
where the show's from
who gives a [ __ ] spent all kinds of
money on this we never see it
put it on a sweatshirt it's an nft but
uh we might have to do it from the beach
and fly i need to go somewhere where
there's a beach
and i need to swim in the ocean i don't
know if i'll be able to swim in the
ocean
uh go to the temperature right now the
water in uh
florida tampa i need to go swim in the
ocean
i i really am uh
right now looking at 69.
i can swim in that right yeah you could
do that right
that's a little cool but it's not
horrible
i might have to just swim in the ocean
down to tampa for a few days after i get
done with houston
and then i'll be back and i have a show
in austin at the paramount i don't know
how many tickets are left i don't know
if there's any tickets left but what's
happening now with all these shows
is the clubs are opening up at higher
capacities so
check even if they've been sold out
check a lot of these dates i have coming
up in denver and miami and places like
that because
what we're seeing happen is more tickets
are added because
we are at now a higher capacity than we
would have been
now the patreon is not video okay
so we know that i know that so much of
the humor
is in the way he most says it in the
moves in the hands
calm down a lot of the humor is just in
the
what's being said so enjoy that you know
you could google image me and put a
photo of me in the google image game and
put photos of us up
if you are upset that
you cannot see us but i love the patreon
episodes i love audio only i mean i love
the
obviously doing the video too but i grew
up with uh you know audio only that's
kind of the way i
uh the ads will be video if you want to
stick around hey the ads are video
isn't that nice all right without
further ado
patreon devin costa and ida are with me
he's a very attractive girlfriend
they've been car shopping with me we're
attractive i know women don't want to
hear that anymore
they want to hear that you're i love
hearing it yeah i know everybody ever
all the women want to hear now that
they're going to be margaret thatcher or
something
but and i don't even mean politically i
just mean that they're all going to be
accomplished but
it's nice to be hot trust it's a nice
thing to be
attractive i don't know when i don't
know how that got flipped
somehow that that's actually not good or
someone shouldn't notice that
don't notice me being attractive
um they've been out here car shopping
with me in the desert
for the past few days how many
dealerships would go to yesterday like
seven
i think seven yeah yeah and and and and
we went to beamer and mercedes and range
rover we just go to all these
dealerships and i don't really know what
car i'm gonna get i wanna get a lease
and
i don't wanna spend that much money but
i just
am addicted now to car sales people
i can't quit them i want them
all the time yeah because it's so
it's such a weird sale you walk on the
lot
it's like anything else they got to be
your best friend within a minute
they got to be they got to turn it on
and some of them do and some of them
don't some of them just really don't
no the range rover people the range
rover people
act like you're doing the wrong thing
they act like they're doing you a favor
and now i'm trying to get a range rover
and i have no credit
and it's a whole problem and this this
desperate
[ __ ] who's trying to sell me the car
first of all i took a road test today
think about this
i went i looked at a range rover i don't
have a license
i the guy the guy thinks he's selling me
the car
i got to tell him afterwards i don't
have a license i don't have a license
so i got to take a road you know this
guy called his wife he's like i got
i got a good prospect he's interested
his friends are here they love the car
and you know he went and told the sales
manager he's like hey bob bob
bob and he's like alan what alan what
i can't take any more money off he's
like no no bob i got a guy
i got a prospect he's just got to take
his driver's test you go
you get the [ __ ] out of the office you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's just got to take a road test
tomorrow that's it but he's good
bobby loves the car bob i did good
alan why don't you go home and cry to
your wife you know he went home and he
sat with his wife
and his wife's like so you think that
you're gonna get any of these off the
lot and he's like i got a guy
i got a guy and then he's like but he's
taking a road test
tomorrow morning and she goes she
probably just looked at him and goes
jesus christ alan
jesus so now [ __ ] alan looks like
he's gonna kill himself
so yeah so alan looks like he's gonna
so we go into because i'm too fat for
every other car i've sat like nine of
these cars
they're like wedging me in with plungers
it's crazy
how small these cart they're all for
europeans
they're all for europe this is the
fattest country in the world
and very little is made for fat people
on the in the high end it's like
or even the mid-end this is not really
that high-end it's whatever but
it says it like rolls royce or whatever
but it's like a nicer car
and a bmw it you have to buy the sedan
like i can't fit in anything but the old
dentist
sedan which i don't want it's the only
thing i fit in
i can't fit in anything else imagine me
and ray kump
in like a a mid-sized bmw i mean it
would be
absurd you have to call the fight you'd
have to get the jaws of life
to get ray out just to if we went
somewhere for lunch
listen get call the fire department
i want a taquito so alan
i'm like all right we're gonna do it
we're gonna get the [ __ ] car
and ellen first of all
alan you know he's in trouble for this
he puts
sold and my name on the car
i don't have a license and my credit i
have one credit card for 800
allen puts sold on the car
you know he's being reamed out for that
like they take him in the bag to go
you're coming before you're even inside
of her
you got this guy's name on the car this
fat [ __ ] doesn't have a license
and he has no credit he's talking about
patreon and ad revenue and
that he just sold out some shows in
dallas what are we doing here alan
alan we're trying to deal with real rich
people
and i'm [ __ ] so he puts sold on it
we go back like you know i give him all
the credit information
and then you know here's the way i live
i just give him the information
and i go and have a butt and i know
what's coming next
like i know it's coming next and by the
way it ain't the keys
it ain't the keys this ain't a rap video
nobody's throwing the keys like hey
partner drive it off
i know it's coming next and it's a lot
of pain
so alan comes out and goes hey you've
never had car credit i said yeah
the last car that i had i bought cash i
spent ten thousand dollars in 2007
on a on a uh uh uh
uh a 1999 chevy suburban the one from
patriot games or clear and present
danger
the i called it the executive vehicle
it's the one that harrison ford drove
a woman named gloria at suzuki 112 and
patchogue
sold me it somehow somehow
oh they i think i got a loan for that
they got me loan for that one i think
that was repossessed
okay but i don't want to go into that
but that was repossessed because
i remember the towing company called me
and they go it's gonna cost
you have so many liens you have so many
problems so many tickets you're gonna
have to pay
a certain amount of money to get this
out of hawk and i went congratulations
and i said what i said on the purchase
of your new suburban
and i hung up the phone and then i just
didn't have a car
for 11 years
for 11 years hey
so the problemo is that uh so then alan
walks out
allen at this point looks like
his son was just killed in iraq
he's going hey uh we got he goes
so then the manager comes out the sales
manager comes out he goes
all right he goes he goes i just did a
deal for a russian gangster who just
like he
he just paid all the lease payments up
front i go well that's not going to
happen so
how about we let's pretend we're dealing
with a non-russian non-gangster
how would we do that like he's trying to
be cool all these car guys trying to be
cool yeah how'd you do to deal with a
russian gangster
and he just sold the house for 28
million dollar and i'm like
hey hey hey none of that calm that the
[ __ ] down
take that testosterone down put a finger
in your ass
stimulate your prostate and get in touch
with your femininity
because none of that hardcock [ __ ] is
gonna happen right now i don't know what
movie you saw
where you think i'm gonna throw a bag of
money at you and drive like what are you
you know
you better let your wife [ __ ] you
tonight you understand
alan you're getting [ __ ] tonight tell
her to put on your strap on
tell you're trying something different
say i want to get
[ __ ] and come from my prostate tonight
honey
so i can better understand how to put
together this deal so the sales manager
there goes hey i'm going to work real
hard on this and hire me for my good
looks and i'm like they didn't hire me
for my good luck
and allen goes you didn't hire me i know
we just both look at him like you shut
the [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] this whole
thing up
i shouldn't even be here
so now chase is land rover financial is
like run their bank is chase
so he goes well you have an account at
chase so this should be easy i'm like
i actually think it'll be much harder i
would prefer the bank to never have met
me
i have no idea who i am what my spending
habits are
or that i even exist so then alan's
trying to get the deal
my business manager god love him you
know he tries
he really does try and you know he's
this is not
this is not uh this is not a shark
right but he's also representing me he
doesn't have a lot to work with right
so he's calling these it's three it's
it's it's defeats the hopeless here
i mean oh it's just a bunch of hopeless
people the three stooges it's the three
stooges
on a conference call trying to put
together this deal and all that but i'm
into it now i'm like feeling it i
remember
because this is the mortgage days i used
to go and go listen man i got a real
good like i remember i was trying to
howie who i talk about a lot
howie was uh one of the most cutthroat
and cutthroat meaning
dishonest and immoral people i'd ever
met but he was also very bad at sales
and didn't know anything about the
products
was completely uneducated but only
succeeded by his
his um ability to lie
in circles like if you ever met somebody
who lies in circles
to the point where you have now bought
into some of their lives
and you have to help make some of their
lives true unless
you're a liar it's actually a great
strategy
if you lie so much and get people to
believe it
they are now invest they're like well i
can't go down with the ship
we gotta write somehow right this wrong
figure it out how he used to do that all
the time
right so how he how he used to try to
refinance these homes
they were called modular homes in like
south carolina because you would call up
these
retards and no offense if you live over
there but not everyone there's a bright
we would call up these people and they
they own modular homes which means it
was driven down the highway on a flatbed
truck
and put in the dirt yeah now modular has
a foundation it has a concrete slab
as a foundation so now howie would also
just try to refinance double wides
that could be driven away and the bank
doesn't want to lend a double wise
because you could just say hey
later hey this didn't work out i'm out
of here so how we would then lie and say
it's a modular
and it's clearly a double wide and then
how we would then claim the borrower
lied to him
and then the sales manager so he'd go in
he'd go to the office he'd go listen he
goes i got a good one
it's a modular it's on a foundation i've
done all the homework don't worry about
it it's all fine and then they would
find out they'd send the appraiser out
your praise will go this is double wide
and how we go this is not a [ __ ]
double wide
i i'm telling you these people are
honest
and then the people don't even know what
they live in like the people don't know
what they live in right they don't know
the difference
they have no idea they're more honest
than he is
so like and i used to go in with deals
that
could never get done i would walk in you
know with some shitty deal and i'd be
like hey man listen
you know they they want a half a million
dollars but they've paid back
they have a kmart card that they've paid
back
and it's got 1200 on it and they they've
they've paid that back every month and
they'd go the
the sales manager go all right we'll try
to get it done man but this
is not this is nothing this is literally
nothing
so that's what alan is that's what
alan's doing he's like this guy's a
comedian he's on the joe rogan show and
they're going
alan i swear to christ if you don't
bring it real
if you don't bring a real buyer in here
i
swear to christ alan we're gonna put you
on the street
and he's like no no no this guy's in a
joe rogan show this guy's a comedian
he's
funny and they go alan i swear to god
this is the third god only knows who
walked in there before me like who he
walked in before me
you know and so this poor guy is trying
i mean we're trying
to put this together and we're going to
find out tomorrow you know at the end of
the day like
he looked into the expedition like ali
looked at me looked at you guys and goes
i can't tell you we're gonna get this
done
and this is not even fake business i
want the goddamn car
he goes yeah i'm not going to tell you
we're going to get this done he's like
but we're going to try we're staying
extra late tonight when the banks open
up tomorrow
that's fun because the by the way the
banks aren't even involved yet
the bank think of all the problems we've
had
the banks aren't even in it
yet they get in it tomorrow like they're
probably talking to like some
underwriter or some processor and
they're like hey
got a guy he's got the money his credit
sucks he wants a lease
you write it off whatever but i feel bad
for allen i hope this comes through
because of alan
i hate allen why do you not like allen
allen sucks
he should have he he was not a good car
salesman he was the first place we went
to
he did nothing he comes out he's already
out of breath the second he walks and
sees you for the first time
right doesn't offer you anything nothing
and what you know you ida loves a
cappuccino she wants to really get
we're in a luxury car dealership yeah
devin made a good point he's like he's
like what what do these people lose by
putting in a [ __ ] coffee machine
yeah i mean navigator gave you a
cappuccino the people they did
people are linking navigation much nicer
couches but then you made a great point
too about how
when when you have a certain level of
money you don't need any of the [ __ ]
the guy looks at me at navigator he
looks at me the guy goes they call it
the land yacht
i wanted to turn around and look at him
and go i have covent
everyone you guys they call it the land
yacht i want to look at him and go
hey man i just tested pasta
for coronavirus
nobody at lincoln wanted to show us the
cars they were just handing it off to
like
dude we called my aunts worked at like
four car dealerships they were all fired
she didn't know anything i'm like tell
me what kind of car to get she goes
she goes i don't know about bmw she goes
what's the middle one
i'm like do you know anything about your
business do you know
i said it's the five series do you know
anything about your business
she goes yeah she goes well they fired
me at mercedes
she goes they're good cars but they
fired me and now she's working for
jaguar and she goes they're gonna fire
me too
they just fire her because she doesn't
know anything about the cars yeah
she like doesn't know none of these card
and then there's a sad little guy in
bentley
this sad little british guy is like
hello mr dylan
and i'm like i'm giving him the number i
can pay every month he's like we can't
mr dylan
there's no way that's going to happen
i'm like i know but is there any way we
could just finagle it and he's like
mr dylan it's not going to happen it's a
different league he keeps telling me
it's a different league it's bentley i'm
like yeah i know but and i know it's
completely unrealistic i'm not getting a
penny but i've been there like three
times in the past week
so i'm like is your juicy anyway he's
like i'll lock you as a person
it's like i'll argue this is how crazy
it is
it's like i'll argue as a person but
he's like i can't he's just this little
emaciated
small guy they all sucked so much ass
i mean they all suck w was cool
he was cool he was cool because he's
like hey hey i got pulled over my
hellcat doing 100. he goes hey
he goes hey i had my kid in the car like
did none of them care about anything
just got my kid in the car the cops know
who i am he said what are you doing i
said i'm trying to go home
doing 100. so what i said the bmw 7
series is big i'm like it's the only one
i fit in but people say it's
uh it makes me look too old you know if
you buy a car like that i mean you lease
a car like that he goes hey
[ __ ] him i bought a cadillac eldorado
and i was 24 years old
like all right tony well that's he kept
telling us to take our masks off
he's like please take your mask dude
alan ben tell
us what alan said we're sitting in
allen's office
as she's putting together this doomed
deal i don't know you guys
politics but uh you republicans are
democrats
because i listen to oann yeah and i go
they got they gotta suspend it on
youtube he goes yeah
because they tell like it is yeah by the
way they got a d platform for
i think pumping a fake coronavirus cure
they're selling an elixir like gypsies
outside of a tent carnival
and they got the platform for that so
that's where they're right he goes he
goes you watch one of them i thought it
was like a joke
like he's like you watch one america
news network i'm like everyone's full
cue
yeah this is not [ __ ] here so i'm
trying to curry favor with him i go
i go hey um
todd just texted me from uh sherman oaks
bentley can't wait to meet you i'm like
i'm not coming in i can't afford i
cannot afford this car right
so then this guy goes you watch one
american news network and i just said
i've had candace owens on my show i
wanted to like try to curry some favor
like let's chop a little bit off the
price
we give candice a platform even though
she's got three million views
uh three million subscribers dummy she's
platforming me i'm not platforming her
is anyone
think with their [ __ ] brain and she
gets more views on a [ __ ]
instagram live than my show whatever
whatever
so we tell him that he goes i've heard
the name candace although he doesn't
even know
like she's too mainstream for him he's
like no if it's not on
if it's not on oan which rogan called
the q a
network he's like if it's because a guy
like that comes home all day tired from
not selling range rovers
and and needs to watch oann
to buy the fake coronavirus cure you
know he's ponied up some money for that
yeah folks sleeping is so important
helix sleep is the way you gotta go they
have a quiz takes two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preference to the perfect mattress
for you
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm
mattresses are great for cooling you
down if you sleep hot even a helix plus
mattress for plus size folks so if
you're
big they got a plus size mattress for
you
don't worry about shrinking we
accommodate you
you don't need to take my word for it
they were awarded number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine
okay just go to helix.com
tim dillon helix dot com tim dillon
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows and
pillows are [ __ ] expensive
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com tim dillon
this is a great way to support the show
if you need a bed it's a great gift for
somebody it's also a great gift for
yourself
uh it's a great gift to give someone the
plus-sized mattress
mattress david dobrik has that big
mattress he took a photo of his big
matchup
he's got all kinds of scandals now i
don't know what happened
they're saying i don't know if this is
true or not but they're saying
have you read about these scandals i
have yeah they're saying that he was
involved
in 911 with the saudis
so i i withhold judgment i don't know
but this is what's being said online is
that david dobrik
had something to do with the saudis and
the attacks of 911.
helix is offering up to 200 for all
mattress orders two free pillows
helix.com tim dillon is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help
help better help hlp will access your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thought thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy
better help hlp is camilla committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if you need
very important they want you to start
living a happier life today
visit their website betterhelp.com
betterhelp.comd that's betterhelp.com
tim d and join over the 1 million people
who have taken charge of their natural
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they're recruiting additional counselors
in all
50 states this pod cancers this pot
cancer
this podcast is sponsored that's a great
title pod cancer
cancer this podcast is sponsored by
better help and tim dillon show
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.comd
off your first month at betterhelp.com
tim d
some [ __ ] die dude my dad wants this
is going all over this episode
but my dad my friend melanie realized
this my stepmother almost died
she ate like chicken that almost killed
her i might when my dad re
told the story to me and my friend
melanie we're standing in the driveway
you could see the piece in his face was
so ready to not be married anymore
and then he was like yeah and then our
neighbor saved her
but he said it was such regret he's like
your neighbor
saw her and saved her she you know but
my dad's like but we almost lost her she
could have been gone
and the the peace in his face when he
said she could have been gone
versus the horror of the neighbor
saving her i mean my my friend melanie
knows
i see if my friend melanie's awake she's
probably not but
she knows it was better than anybody
my friend melanie was there for this
whole thing where my father was
literally like
oh my god because you know he was
married for his
most of his life and then he's got
divorce and he goes i'll get married
again
and then you start realizing halfway
through the second you go i don't what
am i doing
i could just be single what's going on
how are you
pretty good listen to me yeah
what's up so you're on my podcast i
wanted you to tell the story real quick
if you can remember when my father
told us my stepmother almost died and he
was so happy
well there was some there was some guy
who saved her like he
i think his name was melodo or something
like that and i remember your fault like
so he's you know your brain your
stepmother is almost dead and
this guy named a lot of neighbors like
that came over and like saved your life
and i remember your father
like gritted his teeth when he mentioned
this guy's name
he's like a demoloto came over and then
saved her and brought her
and brought it back and let me tell you
something bro
his teeth like gritted and it was like
you know i'll never forget your
stepmother man you can make a podcast
out of her
she's a real guy she's a cold [ __ ] not
because we're kind of trashed around
this episode because i've had about
enough for
she said today i showed my father to
facetime in the house
you know she says she goes how did
somebody who never made any decision
any right decision in his whole life end
up there it's like shut up you [ __ ]
but remember the horrible dinner she
made for my birthday
remember that yeah that was yeah it was
like
it was like rolled cold cuts and [ __ ]
like that it was the worst
it was the most embarrassing just uh
like
display of food for any occasion ever
she's a horrible she was like isn't that
good yeah i love deli food
during a celebration yeah we love we
love we love
ro thanks for the lunchables for
birthdays she's a disgusting person
i know right yeah october special i mean
she's
she's a repulsive witch i think
he's failing remember that with the dog
yes like your dog
your dog's dying like it's all you've
had for years
and and she said i think he's failing
and your dad was like
you're failing yeah yeah christina goes
i think the dog is failing that's the
way she speaks to human beings
that's the way she talks about living
things she's very uncomfortable to me
she prefers death
like when my uncle carl had late stage
brain cancer
she went to the house to be around him
when he died because she prefers death
to life
in a house they got like huntington
yes the witness protection program yeah
it really was i mean
you know i mean your that's funny i
remember like
somebody like you were like sorry you
were practicing like living on the
street
and he got you a coat because i got you
a coat son and it was that blue coat
with like
bird [ __ ] on it that he ripped off some
dark work or somewhere yeah he felt like
a haunt was it was a
coat that was literally from a homeless
shelter from goodwill
that had that had bird [ __ ] on it and he
gave it to me
this is his wife when she moved they got
married in 11th grade
i was in 11th grade and she tried to
convince him to take me on a catholic
school there i
i was dragged to catholic school kicking
and screaming holy trinity
and then she goes take him out in his
senior year now by the way the school
that i would have gone to was lakeview
which is the school of
all gang members and then i went to
summer school there once there was this
italian woman miss ruizi
who used to take her tit out and
breastfeed her kid in the back of class
so that's where my stepmother wanted to
send me to school
to like gain the school from dangerous
minds
and my grandfather had to step in and
pay the money so like
this woman was always like let's get rid
of your kid
so my name is cinderella she really is
like you know you could put a picture
actually i should go into the wikipedia
and upload a picture of her to
stepmother
and just like your average stepmother
face i mean
you know just laughs she basically
isolated
your dad from everybody who we cared
about it's very true
she took him away from his friends she
took him away from his friends
and so they moved into some little
bungalow and now they're selling that
and they're moving to a bigger house up
the block
they're they're just in that era of life
where they're bored
and they need to shuffle things around
before the end
yeah no it's true baby boomers either
get around 70 they start to get bored
and they like to just buy stuff because
they have money
or they die that's that's really what
happens you're a student of the boomer
what is it about these long island
boomers they are fascinating people what
is it
what is it about them they they're
fascinating to me
they literally get anything they wanted
they're used to it
they got everything they wanted i mean
trump's the last former president
that's true obama was a fake uber press
obama was more generation x even though
he was born in 61 but trump is the
perfect example of what happens when a
boomer
is president right that's what happens
folks you know
yeah but um which of them call it uh
i could go on and on about about
bloomers i mean
you know a high school diploma you own a
house like at the age of 20. you know
what i mean
it's unbelievable and they're always
aggrieved they're always aggrieved like
when you speak to them they
act like they're nothing went right and
they suffered for
like i remember when my aunt was talking
about covered my aunt donna goes she
goes you know i just
i want everyone to stay inside and put
mask on she goes because you know what i
want to travel
because she goes i deserve it because
i've worked hard my whole life i'm like
and the way she said it then i realized
i'm like everyone's worked hard their
whole life
yeah everybody's worked hard their whole
life you know not all of us get like a
new car when we're 18.
right you know i mean my mother got a
new car when she was 18. she
by the way she worked at a place called
the farmers market and she managed to
save up enough money to buy a brand new
car machine ap
now i have never bought a brand new car
and i've
like worked like a slave my entire life
right
so my newest car i just bought my newest
car from 1995
the truck it's like all rusty what'd you
get so
it oh i had to get a pickup truck cause
i'm like
i'm almost full of hillbilly at this
point i love it the gun rack in the back
window is the next thing
you better get you better get the guns
man we better all get the guns because
[ __ ]
i'll tell you right now biden and kamala
man i don't know what they're going to
do but i i'd feel a lot better with an
arsenal
uh yeah actually which of the call well
you wanted this to be funny is that all
the gun stocks like
smith and west and everything like that
took a dive after buying one because
because people were like all right well
we only have to get like military gear
to deal with ryan
i don't know if you noticed all the
rides that disappeared all of a sudden
you know i see a lot of republicans you
know you don't see a lot of
republicans fighting uh or anything like
that yeah
brian and i just you know they gave him
a softball interview today i i'm
constantly watching him waiting in the
gap or something like that
it'll be fun uh you know what
because you'll go back to sleep and
that'd be good yeah i mean i agree with
you there
i think it's very impossible the country
just goes back to sleep but i think this
is what these people want
when you see them all out cheering and
dancing and stuff even though
supposedly according to them there's a
huge pandemic that's killing everyone
and then they go right back out to
dancing in the street that's like oh
are you people on crack i mean what was
the last time you danced in the street
about
anything never never melody
maybe maybe scoring drugs and stuff like
that back in the day after waiting in my
car for an hour
yes
deeply childish country how
childish forget it i know right
it's what like one old a 78 year old man
wins the presidency
and everybody's in the street dancing
sneezing on each other you know
the disease and everything like that
it's like go in your [ __ ] houses my
friends
yeah go in your houses and celebrate in
shame like all of us should
right there's no more shame anymore
there's no more
you know nobody has any shame
everybody's addicted to having
friends and all these disgusting
it's disgusting if i see somebody over
the age of 30
and they have 20 friends i go that
person is severely mentally
if you're more than five friends over
the age of 30 you're severely mentally
ill
totally and it's because they were
always bullied when i was a kid i didn't
have any friends i'm like
who was it you know what i mean yeah who
didn't get a wedgie when they were like
right by like some teenagers i mean i'm
a teenager one time just decided robert
he grabbed me and my brother we put it
to the trunk of his car
he drove around in the freezing weather
for like an hour
and he dropped us off in a place we had
no idea where we were it was like a kid
it's technically with the kidnapping
and uh this guy this guy later died at 9
11. i'm not kidding he's got a 911
well you get what you give
melanie angler i you are the best do you
want people to follow you on social
media i always give people you're a
human being so
i always give people the choice tell
people where they can follow you
instagram melody english yeah now i need
to uh
underscore english underscore yeah
that's about it
y-e-a-h yeah
i mean i'm into a podcast right now i
don't even want to talk too much about
it
but i'm into this podcast i got to talk
a little bit about i know we've just
been avoiding talking about i know
i know but it's like here's the thing i
get into like i don't get into a lot of
content out there
but there's a podcast that has no views
if you go to youtube it has one view
two views i'm the only one i feel
special i'm the only
i'm the only one consuming this content
and it's a guy who's like 500 pounds who
does a weight loss podcast
out of long island he's like a comedian
in every episode as he just
talks about what he ate literally and he
just goes yeah
i stayed on my plan today i stayed on my
points i
uh you know you know today i had an
omelette and
i could do an away in tomorrow and it's
not funny at all like he's a
really fat guy and he does a weight loss
podcast you think there'd be a lot of
opportunity there for
you know levity you know comedic you
know
nothing i mean just nothing just dry
just kind of like he's talking to a
friend like and then he goes
every now and then he's like hey the
live podcast is postponed due to corona
and i'm like
the live podcast you're gonna do this
live like you're gonna sit there
live and tell people about your weigh-in
it's like the craziest
it's the craziest thing and i knew this
guy a little bit like he wasn't a nice
guy so i don't really care
but i'm also like if you stumble upon
what this podcast is
don't [ __ ] on the guy or whatever this
is just what he does i'm not [ __ ] on
him
it's just fascinating to me that
someone it just does and i'm a fat guy
like i get wanting to lose weight
and if i you know when i try to lose
weight i talk about it but like
this guy just it's every episode it's
very dry
there's no humor and he just like he had
one guy
on he had one guy on
you got to play that ben can we find a
way to play that
well then they'll be able to find it i
don't think we should play sounded
anyway but
so he has one guy on who's like a health
no by the way he
brings up like a health food guy like a
natural food chef this guy's 500 pounds
can we stop with the natural foods like
just
just like don't let the perfect become
the enemy of the good here
okay so he has this natural food chef on
and he goes hey man so what started
eating healthy this guy launches into a
10-minute tirade this natural food shaft
about that he used to [ __ ] 50 times a
day and he had crohn's
and he's his skin was bad and he had
rashes
and his friends were dying his friend
died of stomach cancer at 40
and the other guy doesn't and then he
and the natural food chef goes
listen man you know i used to eat and
then this the guy is hosting the podcast
says nothing
he says nothing he's just going through
tragedy after tragedy
like i've never heard it and the host of
the podcast doesn't say anything until
the guy goes you know and i used to eat
like [ __ ] you know i like doughnuts and
maple bars and those of the podcast goes
who doesn't that's all they say goes who
doesn't
this guy has just detailed one of the
craziest things i've ever heard just
everyone he knew died
he just he like he was failing at a
school because he just kept [ __ ]
and apparently it was because of his
diet and this guy hosting the podcast is
just like not even
aware of what's even happened like it's
just cut i
can't list anything even remotely good
so like when people ask me like what do
you listen to i try to find like the
worst
things to enjoy like the word like to
understand like
i need to be constantly befuddled like
if i understand something i'm almost out
immediately like i get it
right like i'll enjoy it but like i'm
not i'm not a freak like i like funny
[ __ ] right
but i am a freak because like i i
salivate when there's a new episode of
this podcast i'm like this is my podcast
and literally if you look at the views
i'm the only one listening to it
i'm the only person really listening to
this podcast in the continental united
states
and every now and then he'll come out
and he'll be like hey uh we're number
four in a health
and fitness podcast in cameroon so i
want to thank everyone in cameroon
i'm like cameroon like it's it's so
crazy
it's gonna be all over the reddit i
don't know what to do i mean whatever i
mean whatever happens i just
it's more viewers right than the guy
gets like is it is it
it's more listers than he would get it's
the more listeners that he would get
right
i just don't understand like i don't
understand what he's doing and i listen
to it and i'm like is this a call to a
friend you should be having like
he's putting this out as a podcast it's
so
bad that it's i can't stop
it's so bad it's good like it's so
so bad like he'll be like yeah i can't
wait to go back to the regular weight
watchers meeting uh with sheila
sheila lost 50 pounds you worked real
hard sheila worked real hard
and i'm like why am why can i not
stop listening to this why can i not
stop
he goes he says about thanksgiving he
goes you know some people make a plan
for thanksgiving he's like i'll tell you
what i do
i eat because i eat on thanksgiving i
make it a day
you guys say the family's there he
talked about
that he was too fat to watch his nephew
that he
and then he apparently people started
letting him watch his nephew so he's
like
i know i'm turning the corner and i'm
happy about that
again you can't put this stuff out as a
comedian
and not expect people to have a reaction
to the like it's i'm happy he's now
watching his nephew
it's just a crazy thing to hear and i'm
happy he's losing weight like i'm not
hating on it
but when he's talking about being too
big
to watch your nephew and now he's like
now i can watch the nephew
because i've turned a corner and he's
lost like 200 pounds god bless him
he was always a dick to me and to
everyone else when we did comedy
but i i still i i want no ill will i
want this show to like be bigger because
it's my favorite podcast
no it's truly my it's it's truly like
the only podcast i listen to a portion
of
every episode i've gone back to the
archive
i'm i'm i'm shocked by it it's shocking
and maybe it's like one of the greatest
things ever done
it's just there's never an attempt at
humor and it's just a serious solemn
accounting
of his weak in losing weight and i'm
like there's
nothing even remotely funny about this
but yet
this is how cheap and hollow comedy is i
would so much rather go
see his live podcast than 99 of
anyone that i know to sit in a room and
hear him do that just sit on a stool and
be like
well today i was even on the scale again
and sometimes you go united way and
naked he goes maybe this is tmi
but i weigh a nick and i'm like own it
don't tell people there's no such thing
as tmi it's
put it out there yeah but it's so
strange
i mean what are your impressions of it
you've you've heard it
it's so tragic i mean it's it's
it's tragic but listen my life is tragic
everything's trash i mean listen
my life is tragic not coming out of
clouds
i'm 25. i mean listen i have a rough
like i mean not
now because i'm making money and
everything and i get to do what i love
i'm not trying to get on the whole thing
here
but like i don't see myself as less
tragic than him i mean i guess
whatever you now i am
but like i i i come from tragedy i come
from like
a sexless loveless life for the majority
of my life like
being ashamed of who i am and all this
stuff i mean i'm not trying to play the
fiddle here
but i'm not trying to shoot on someone
else and go your life is tragic
i mean i've listened to the pi it ain't
great
but that's his it is can you use a
different word than tragic
uh uh it's like it's funny not everybody
gets to be a good-looking golfer and
falls in love with a chick in college
you know some of us have problems
it's like it's like when i listen to it
it's like
it's like funny to your bones like it's
the way he just
deadpan delivers like every m my
like just the minutia of his life from
every way it's either he doesn't know
what he's doing
or he's an underappreciated comic genius
in a way and i don't think it's choice b
but i i don't know but i will tell you
this
i laugh on that show he's not trying to
make me laugh
but what he's saying sometimes is like
brutally funny it is
and i i think if he knew it was funny it
would ruin it yeah it would
he's like an andy kaufman type thing i
don't know what's going on
i just know i don't know if this means
anything to him i have an audience to
hundreds of thousands of people
and you you are my favorite podcaster
it's true though it's my favorite
podcast it's my favorite body i think
it's very funny
there's a brilliance to it that i don't
know if he understands or that i'll ever
understand
he had his sister on and she goes
[Laughter]
with ben with there anyway he has his
sister-in-law and she goes
he goes you know i'm not really losing
she goes you're eating too much food he
goes you don't understand he starts to
get mad
again there's no comedic bone like he's
not going back at her in a funny way
she goes you're eating too much food and
he goes no you don't understand
he goes a lot of those times i'm under
my points like on weight watchers have
the points he goes
you don't understand like uh
he goes a lot of those days when you
look at the points i'm actually under
eating
and she just shoots him a look she goes
you don't need the pancakes and the eggs
and
he goes but no no it's under my it's
under my points
and he goes i'm under eating he's
arguing with her that he's under eating
and he's like 400 pounds and she's
staring at him
and to me it's some of the greatest
comedy i've ever
i've truly ever seen in my life yeah
like i've
never seen like you have a 500 pound guy
arguing that he's
under-eating dead face
straight face like not a skin till of
irony not a joke
not a moment of levity to be had and
he's getting mad and you can see it and
and and you feel the tension between
both of them
and to me i'm like there's this is real
this is funny
this is what i like
you can wind up and throw all kinds of
jokes out i don't even [ __ ] right
but there's something about a big guy
yeah going you don't understand
i'm under eating that's the problem
if there's any problem instead i'm under
eating yeah it's like a christopher
guest
like sketch almost yeah yeah so i'm just
saying that's my favorite podcast do
that do it do with it when you will
so the king of comedy and that
those are my favorite podcasts
i'm not attacking the guy i enjoy it i
just he's a
he's kind of a nasty guy he admits that
he's a nasty guy
he says i'm kind of a prick he's a prick
but i
like that he kind of owns that and i
think the show's actually
very strange so if you listen to this
you find out figure out what it is which
you all will in
30 seconds probably
you're going to be like why does tim
like this but then maybe you just don't
understand the wavelength i'm on yeah
because i think it's funny
i mean i just i think it's funny i was
just waiting for you to talk about it
i had to talk about it i'm making ben
listen to it now it's so good it's so
good
i mean no every week i want to know
about the after thanksgiving weigh-in
all he took by the way i don't think
he's mentioned the pandemic
the the race war the civil war the
economic collapse donald trump
it's just weight loss
every week you would think that he would
just go like
hey those riots huh just an aside
but he never does he just stays
and he just does that stuff he goes you
know if you believe it it can happen he
goes you just gotta put in the work
and you gotta and it's like i don't know
man
every comedian is tragic right we're all
tragic that's the whole point
and then when the there's comedians that
aren't tragic and they're you know
whatever it's like is that
i don't know that's never the comedy
i've enjoyed right doesn't mean like you
could see a really good looking comic
and you could be like
oh what is why does that guy have to be
funny that guy's got it all but then you
meet them and you go oh they're tragic
yeah they're like deeply tragic they
can't feel it's horror
so i'm not ever judging anyone
i guess i am a lot though
but what i'm saying is take this for
what it is
understand what i'm saying here this is
my favorite podcast
i love it i love it
i'll be driving in the car and i'm
eating a flame fishing i wonder how many
points
this has and he just goes on he goes
yeah you know this week
i'm down .02 which i don't even know
what that means huh
some like fraction of a pound 0.02 okay
it's like a fraction he goes but we're
still down
but i wanted more and next week i'm
gonna have more
but again nothing not like it would be
so easy to throw in a joke i think
that's what's interesting yeah
but he doesn't do it and i almost liked
it he died if he tried to be funny on
this thing i would hate it yeah
it would be like i can't even do it but
the fact that he's just
day in and day out just doing it
i i'm like i respect it i like like the
show
i mean maybe he hears this or something
he thinks is like an attack it's not an
attack
i'm confused but i also enjoy it
and i think it's awesome he lost so much
weight i mean it's incredible
yes yeah it's a lot of weight i mean all
the disclaimers here that we can make
yeah
my point is that when i hear the show i
don't know what i'm listening to
but i can't stop listening now if that's
if that's bad you don't understand what
good is
because if i'm not stopping listening i
was gonna buy one of the meal bars that
sponsors him
he's also sponsored by a deli i was
gonna go there but it's in new york
but my point is that if the test of
anything is just that i don't turn it
off
it's hard for me to turn off i don't
like when he has guests sometimes the
guests are really good
yeah but i like him solo yeah he's just
got to go solo yeah
he's just got to do it solo
this is the type of these are the type
of podcasts i really enjoy like podcast
that shouldn't exist
and do because what a podcast is just
somebody with a mic going hey here it is
here it is now this is uh what we're
doing
i mean they're so bad dude so many
podcasts are so
bad i mean they're just bad because
these are the same people
that wouldn't know
it's like there are people out there
that are really under the impression
they're attractive
and i guess that gets the mask because
people like confidence right
yeah but then there are the people that
are under the impression that they're
interesting
that gets you nowhere like if you if you
can't hold someone's interest with what
you're saying
and you think you can that just gets you
me
that just gets you me as a fan because i
want to like
just i i want to know why what this is
because that to me is fascinating i like
authentic
and real and there's nothing more
authentic and real than this podcast
there's nothing in it that should happen
there's not one choice made that's the
correct choice
but here's the thing how many podcasts
fail miserably
making all of those right choices right
right
so no no comedic choices are made that
are correct
but that being said now we're getting
into what makes it truly great
because it's
crazy it's not i couldn't even call it
bad
it's just i don't know why it exists
and i can't stop listening to it and i
don't want it to end
i want him to lose enough weight i guess
where he doesn't have to do anymore but
i can't not listen
to it because of the severity and the
seriousness
and he's not like an unfunny guy like
he's not the funniest guy
like at all but
the choices he makes to not be funny at
all i think it's phenomenal
i think it's absolute i think it's kind
of brilliant
in a level that no one would appreciate
outside of me that's why i am the view
he puts in an episode it has one view i
am the view
every time i get mad when there's like
four views i'm like who are they
this is for me he refreshed it twice
someone hit it by accident and then i'm
the view my average listen is the whole
episode
oh i do the whole episode sometimes i do
it in bits
you know i'll be rocking out in a car
and then i go let me give 50 minutes to
him
and then i go back to music and then i
go back to listening to something i did
to see if i could use the word um too
many times
and then i go back to him and he's
talking to somebody from his weight
watchers group
and i'm like like i don't know why
maybe i i am a fat guy i get it i get
how hard it is to be able to be a fat i
mean
it's tough man it is hard to lose weight
it's difficult i'm trying i've been
trying i think if i really focus i could
pull off like 40 pounds
i'll never be thin there's a certain
time in your life
when the six-pack like you got to give
that up that people go
no you can still have hey shut up hey
hey hey
go preach that [ __ ] with gary vee i
don't have the time
i do real fake business but
i i do want to survive i'm a godfather
to a kid now
you know and i mean dan but no i'm a
godfather to my friend's son
and my friend and his wife let's be
honest they're degenerates i'm gonna
have to raise that kid
i mean these two are like and i respect
them but they're
they're they're animals you know oh yeah
i mean they're
animals and i i want to survive because
i'm like
this kid i want to
i want to do the right thing and and be
able to help the kid out or whatever and
like
she want to lose weight like i gotta get
healthier i gotta survive this covens
[ __ ] makes you think you're like yeah
man i gotta
i gotta pull together so as a fat guy i
know let me light a cigarette as i say
that i wanna survive
i just wanna throw me the lighter but as
a fat guy we're gonna go long here we're
gonna go a few minutes longer folks
i'm sorry we're just gonna have to do a
little longer for your five dollars or
twenty dollars for the rothschilds
remember that daily show [ __ ] jenna
friedman was like ah it's anti-semitic
do you have a rothschilds here like
[ __ ] will you shut up
she said that she made some allusion to
it on twitter i'm like [ __ ] no one
thinks that all jews are the rothschilds
jenna that's absurd okay
that's like thinking all comedians are
you
as i like my marble light which i think
is not bad for you
but i do and and please don't i don't
patreon on my phone so i don't really
know what your comments are i can't
because i'll fight with you people all
day
i can't be involved and i won't get
anything done it's not even that i don't
feel that you're worthy of fighting i
just can't i won't get anything done
it's why i don't go on things
i just won't get anything done and i'll
just end up
fighting with everybody all day that's
like well why didn't you say this i'm
like
i did listen to this like
and at a certain point but i've hired a
trainer
who's dead of covert
up now that is sad
no but i i'm trying to get it together
so as a fat guy when i listen to this
podcast
i get it i get the the yo-yoing and the
[ __ ] and it going up and down you do
keto you lose dirty
you look a little better you start going
at the ego let me get a handful of
calamari and i look good
you could hook up with an attractive
person if i hook up with an attractive
print the day after i hook up with them
i eat like you have no idea
i mean i just go okay i got that in
now let's really kill like abuse myself
and i just eat
like you know bad so i know what that
feels like because you can't get rid of
food you can get rid of drugs i got rid
of drugs and alcohol
so like
but it's just so funny to do it the way
he does it
was like deadly serious i like it so
much better
god don't ruin it with jokes don't ruin
it with jokes
and listen if i'm the only fan let me be
the only fan
it's a better fan than so many don't
have 2
000 fans that are nobodies i am a big
podcaster and i'm telling you right now
this is my [ __ ] that's my show that
podcast is my show
when he comes on and he starts talking
and he's got a guest on talking about
somebody's [ __ ] bled and some guy's
bleeding out of his [ __ ] all day and
that's why i decided to stop eating
doritos
that's my show cause it's so crazy
like but she said neil had a good point
once he's like it's funny to say i'm
dying from sugar
yeah it's like funny you know
but it truly is one of those things
where it's like people struggle with
their weight their entire life and then
my mother was overweight people don't
understand what it's like to struggle
with your weight go back and forth you
you were a little chubby when you were
boozing but you you 235
my biggest yeah when i cut the booze
though i lost like 30 pounds yeah
yeah but that
is that's big 235 is pretty big for you
yeah because i'm 180 now
185 yeah so yeah
but i think my biggest i was like 340
330. i was big
i was big and it's like it really is
tough
when you are somebody that just goes
back and forth but i listen to this
podcast and i'm like
there's just nothing better out right
now
there's just nothing better when he goes
because thanksgiving he goes i eat
he goes thanksgiving he goes i eat i
make a day of it
with the family i get there early
they're cooking
and i eat it just it takes over your
life
so that's why i stopped going to aaa and
i'm not telling anyone to stop going aa
by the way if you go to a
but i went to a for a while but i also
got to a point where i go
do i want to sit in a room and talk
about booze for the next 40 years
the answer is no by the way that's not
what aa is and i'm not trying to
delegitimize a.a because i think it's
great in the beginning and
for many people throughout their entire
life it would not hurt me to go back to
meeting at all
ever um it's good but
you know i got to a point with it where
i went
you know aa's got a five percent rate of
success meaning that i think five
percent of people stay in it i think
it's got a much higher rate of success
when you look at
how many people have utilized important
skill sets
uh an important skill set or a knowledge
base from that about themselves
and then they just move on and it
doesn't mean that there means you can
move on
you don't have to you know but i moved
on because i'm like i don't need and
that doesn't mean if you're in month two
is sobriety it's time for you to move on
don't listen to this podcast but
it's time for me to move on um
but i got to a point where i go didn't
you go to an a meeting once you're like
it's super depressing
well it reminded me of uh church
everyone had the crosses and the praying
and i did that for 21 years it just
right yeah it was upsetting yeah it's
really upsetting
here's the thing about an aaa meeting
when you go to one you better make sure
you're done drinking because drinking
won't be fun
it'll ruin drinking for you if you're
just a casual drinker this may be
drinking a little too much
don't go to an a meeting if you're an
alcoholic like i am and like ben is
you know it's good to see you can't ever
drink again no
no never no no and at the aaa meeting
you know i saw
people that got sober really late after
they've lost everything they're like i
lost my house
yes family and it's like jesus christ
it's
it's heavy it's really it's heavy
they've lost it all but it's still good
to be sober
yeah those people dying sober is a gift
yeah
die sober as a gift you know
and i mean i'll die sober i will never
drink again i'll never smoke pot again
i'll never
i don't really want to do psychedelics
or shrooms or dmt it doesn't i had my
time for that
i had my time i you know i don't need to
go on ayahuasca retreats and
all these [ __ ] losers in la that are
i'm sober i used to have a joke in my
act i still do but i just did joke i do
in la where i'm like
it's la sober if you ever ask anyone
who's sober in l.a they're like yeah i'm
sober man i'm not drinking they're like
i still smoke pot a little bit i do
shrooms in xanax i was on an ayahuasca
retreat i'm a shaman actually
i lead them you know and i'll take pills
every now and then some painkillers some
barbiturates suboxone methadone i have a
card i go to the clinic
you know and uh heroin you know
intravenous though you know i don't
snort that [ __ ] i just
i do heroin you know there's nothing
wrong with heroin really other than the
you know withdrawals and the addiction
but you know clean needles go down
needle exchange
but i uh you know but i don't i don't
drink beer
i'm not some drunk
so yeah i mean i don't wanna
i don't wanna plug the podcast because
i've said only nice things about it
though
that's the thing i've only said nice
things so i feel
i don't know what uh we gotta find a rug
outside for this [ __ ]
i've only said nice things about it and
i wish everyone the best i hope he keeps
losing weight i will keep listening to
it
yes the companies that advertise on the
show are a super great product
or they're they give me money sheath
underwear.com we talk about sheath all
the time they're great they're great as
underwear they're great as a bathing
suit
you use it there's a pouch where you can
put your balls and your junk in it
uh the uh the owner robert was a
veteran of the wars
uh the just wars that have accomplished
much
and he's now back selling underwear um
and that's
he got the idea for sheath underwear
in iraq and people don't know this but
um one of the materials that they would
use
the kind of you know stretchy but strong
material that they would use um
to make these little kind of to kind of
mummify the people
that would mummify the people after they
were killed
uh at respect for the religion and what
he did was he said this is a great
material that we use for mummifying the
corpses of the dead
we should make it into underwear and
also give people a pouch for their
drunken balls
which is so important and uh
i i just respect that i really really
respect that and i think it's really
great
when people are inspired by their
environments and come up with something
great
and um you know it's great it's all i
wear
they're the best you have to try it
yourself you got to give them a google
sheets underwear.com do
some research it's interesting his story
is inspiring this guy robert and i don't
say that a lot
but to me it is very inspiring
um to just i mean when you look at what
he's done
and the fact that he's never been
court-martialed
or really sent to the hague for war
crimes
is so inspiring to me that he's just
kind of
sidestepped that somehow and is back
selling underwear
comfortable underwear is so great
to me um that he was able to kind of get
away with everything he did
um i mean one of his big quotes was
terrorists have no age
and that was such a meaningful thing
because a lot of people like we
shouldn't shoot a baby
but he said terrorists have no age and
he would
i mean just total war is what he would
wage
in these towns total war he was not one
of these guys you know you see the
soldiers playing the
soccer with the kids that wasn't him he
was in it to win it
so he would just straight up walk around
fallujah
shooting children in the face like in
the face and it's
you know so many the great moral
questions of our time have no easy
answers
and i'm just a supporter of someone
who's takes action
there was a story once this is one of my
favorite stories and this is and we'll
then we'll get out of the ad but
this is a story once where
he and this is something that and i
don't think he's into this sexually
but he raped a dog in front of a family
and and he and the commitment
to it in iraq he raped a dog
in front of a family and
and then he broke the dog's neck as he
was coming
sheath underwear dot com use code tim
to save 20 folks your car insurance is
ripping you off it's just the way it is
but you can go
to gabby gabby.com
tim dillon they compare all of the
different rates you could be getting
gabby customers on average save 961
dollars per year
i bet that'd be nice to have in your
pocket every year this time of year we
go shopping for insurance gabby takes
the pain out of shopping and gives you
an apples-to-apples comparison of your
current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers progressive
nationwide and travelers just link your
current insurance account in just
minutes you'll be able to see quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have that's what i did
i had my business guy do it so easy
they save a lot of money if they can't
find you savings like they did for me
they'll let you know so you can relax
knowing you have the best rate out there
and they don't sell your info
and there's no annoying spam or robo
calls like i mentioned earlier
i mean this is just something that you
don't lose at all doing you link your
current insurance account in just
minutes you'll be able to see quotes
for the exact same coverage you
currently have
you're probably overpaying for car
insurance and home insurance
it's totally free to check and there's
no obligation you go to gabby.com
tim dillon that's g-a-b-i dot com slash
tim dillon
gabby.com tim dillon
that's the move you save money on
insurance or you don't
but now you know you have the power of
knowledge i love new york i don't want
it i'm just
in in terms of pure comedy there's
nothing funnier
than a a 120 pound white kid from
vermont
tweeting that we don't need cops just
getting
raped to death on the williamsburg
bridge here's the problem there's
nothing funnier than that
i think what's going to happen is like
those people will leave and like
the new york times that sustained all
that violence
like was like actual people who lived
here it wasn't like people who like you
know
came here to be a clown and and then
like bounce as soon as you know like you
know
applebee's clothes you know whatever the
[ __ ] i mean well there was a lot of
people that came here to be artists that
just stuck it out that were tough back
in the day
but me and you always talked about
you're gonna get all that violence and
all that poverty
and none of the art dude you get none of
it my boss
you know was saying when trump got
elected
uh he was like speaking to the company
going like
hey you know uh this is not great but uh
it might be on the the silver lining
might be that you know we returned
toward
you know an age of great art you know
[ __ ] punk and [ __ ] this and that
not one thing not one fraction of that
came true
not one thing for all the turbine on
both sides both sides
neither you know there's been time in
recent in decades
when both sides have been this amped up
and felt like you know whether whether
you feel like you're
you know white supremacist or feels like
your country slipping away or
all the other people either i mean no
one's made anything of substance
on either side it'd just be great to
like bring these guys back and like
bring duke ellington
back and go put your horn down just hand
the microphone go
what'd you do today he's like what like
this is what we do now for
eight hours every day he goes what are
you talking about go
that's the only way to make a living now
what do you think what do you think
about things
together goes i just want to play the
[ __ ] you know whatever
the a train or whatever i don't know
what he [ __ ] you know we're like no
no just talk about your wife
it's a [ __ ] smell what about your wife
talk about your wife's [ __ ] for three
hours
he goes what it's just like
you want to talk about art this is the
collapse of art
in in such a total and absolute way you
can't even imagine it coming back can
you imagine if someone did make a
seminal work of art right now like no
one would give a
[ __ ] who would appreciate it we're all
morons
like this
i mean can you imagine one of the these
random movies that
amazon produces for like you know just
streaming on prime was like the next
godfather we wouldn't even know it who
gives it like
yeah we'd be like this sucks
this thing sucks i want to watch cobra
kai
season four by the way i'm really
excited for the season four of cobra
kind because it's people are like it's
too white
i can't wait i just hope there's a flick
a third there's got to be a fourth dojo
now
ran by like a morbidly obese black chick
who's like y'all want to learn karate
you don't want to look ready and they're
like who's this and they're like
this is shamika's dojo
shamika's like yeah like i i love
karate and the show is pretty diverse
isn't it i mean like it's got a lot of
different
reasons not enough not enough i thought
the problem was because like there was
no
it was like specifically that there was
no japanese main character i don't know
the problem is that lizzo isn't running
a dojo right
they the problem is that they haven't
injected a storyline that makes
no sense and is completely not grounded
in reality
and is laughably cartoonish you know
it's rake it's it's like me and you
saying there's not enough fat people in
baywatch
you know we're fat we don't want to
watch fat people in baywatch
what the [ __ ] that like you want to
watch lifeguards be hot
and save people it's like a cra i never
watched baywatch
when but there there's no one that looks
like me
i think i think it could have helped you
though you you could have you could have
been
think about how much more confident you
would be if there was a fat kid on
baywatch
who looked like you you could i mean but
that kind of confidence would be so
destructive
you know they would you by the way
you're right
and that kind of ca i could see of no
way
to getting to be a true sociopath
than if i grew up watching fat kids on
baywatch
jump around in the water i mean i would
be a i'm pretty confident now
for for for like no real reason
the idea that if we just watched fat
whales
frolicking on a beach can you imagine
what monsters we would have become
i don't know i don't even know what i
don't know where this ends honestly it's
like
yeah the kids just like
i i who who's looking at like when is
the what did the answer become like
mainstream culture like wasn't the whole
point
of like everything we learned even in
school was like oh don't
don't follow the like when you jump off
a roof when you jump off a fence or
whatever
cliff like yeah you jump off a bridge
would he do it yeah
and it's like was no idea like to be an
outspoken person
when did we start going like if you're
if you're not represented by corporate
like
things that we still use to sell french
fries then somehow you don't matter
like that's the weird that that's like a
bizarre angle of it
i get like i'm not an idiot i get the
other point like
yeah if you don't grow up seeing black
or black you don't grow up seeing black
people yeah i get that to a point
but at a certain point we're just like
asking who can sell [ __ ] you know
shrimp fest every year but it's also
like
it's just like what did we grow up and
want like home improvement we grew up
and watching an idiot go like
i like tools like there was no
no no like what did i learn that i could
be an idiot
like all i learned is i'm gonna get
caught by my wife every every week
yeah we're gonna learn that i'm gonna
have a show called tool time about
sauce like what i don't understand like
the drew cat like the drew carey shot
could be some fat idiot
with some like i don't even know what he
did like i don't even know like
what were these shows supposed to
inspire us to even do he
his friends in season four or five
started their own like you know micro
brewery or something
and they would just make beer and with
caffeine in it uh
that like and it's also like dude it's
like roseanne like
most shows we watched the families were
like [ __ ] yeah like roseanne's family
was [ __ ]
they were fortunate they had no money
they tried to they tried to start a
loose meat restaurant
remember that yeah yeah yeah
it's like yeah it's like wait a minute
what did we learn from watching rosanna
you could work at a diner
and eventually and eventually like fall
for q anon like
what exactly what exactly was the great
lesson
from all these what like i guess you had
to go back to like family ties
alex p keaton like there was like a few
shows where like they were but like
but everything is better if it's just
jay-z and beyonce like isn't that better
it's not like a more right
a kind of more concentrated like
diluting it into this we believed all
kinds of [ __ ] like mr belvedere it's
like oh i guess i'll get a butler one
day
i guess my parents will move some fat
british pedophile
into my house hey that guy what was the
story there why was he where are they
i think he just [ __ ] the kids
[Laughter]
i mean it's like everything we grew up
with it was like mr belvedere
some dude just by the way the house
wasn't even like that big
right they clearly weren't that rich
they just had this middle-aged british
man
that wasn't thinking like he clearly
wasn't there like normal it wasn't a
normal thing he'd be their butler it was
like
he was just like living with them like
yeah different
harry in the hand was like legit harry
and the hendersons
where it's like oh bigfoot lives in the
house
like a sasquatch lives in the house like
would any race have been better if there
was a family that adopted a sasquatch
that lived with them like it's just when
you unpack this you're like what exactly
are you did you want like step by step
that blended family
with suzanne summers and patrick duffy
right on tgif where like
that the whole family hated each other
because still like it was from just this
weird divorce
it was all tragic
i'm trying to remember like the shows
yeah we're like they were there
they were probably they're probably
cheating with each other before they got
divorced like those kids probably
hate the other one yeah it was a broken
home
yeah step by step it's like that's what
you say to
drug addicts who are trying to get clean
like and then there was like
the show's like friends where it's like
yeah you could live in new york city and
be a failed actor and
live in a big apartment and earn no
money and like all these
unrealistic horrible shows that like
doomed us to failure
right they're like doom friends made it
cool to have like nine roommates into
your 40s
that's a great point it's actually the
most destructive thing is seeing
yourself on the
reflected background it's the worst idea
asians didn't have it they're doing
great
like they're doing great they didn't
need to be an asian version a friend
with seven
asian losers they can't do they can't
[ __ ] remember to get milk unless nine
of them go to the
what is this i just don't understand
it's when you unpack it you're like
maybe the worst thing in the world is
that we saw ourselves on tv
right dennis france in nypd
blue i too can be a fat racist cop good
thank god beverly hills 90210
like yeah like oh that's realistic i
could be hot
and 35 and play a teenager like i can
be in uh in a high school it's like well
no he's not
everything it was like the real world
and these are the reality show they're
growing up watching reality shows and
getting onto reality shows like
it's a cycle of just like
and then you know they have a kid and
they get diabetes i don't know
how it ends but it's like it's just it
really is already like a dystopian
[ __ ] novel it's [ __ ] it's
grotesque
yeah i mean it's like teen moms and it's
like 19th season yeah
it's like they're not even teen moms
here but they're like 46.
it's just like crazy i don't know if i
can have his kid like
you're a lawyer yeah
we went to go look at apartments today
uh just to see them and you know who
knows i think
i talked about it on the main show it's
like maybe the move is an apartment
so we went to this building uh in uh
santa monica
which is a real citrus city century city
a real high-end
building just to look at it see what's
going on over there
really hot woman uh uh
walks you know first of all when we walk
in these buildings like ben walks in
first and they're like
hello and then i walk in i'm like hello
and they're like oh
they're like are you and i'm like i'm
the decision maker and they're like
right okay uh so then they're all like
well i guess
we by law have to show you these things
and i'm like
correct correct so we go on a tour
of this apartment the woman looks at me
she goes we have a gym you don't need to
see the gym
right i'm like no i believe you there's
a gym so then she goes you get free
complimentary breakfast it's like when
you're a fat person you just treat it
like this all the time
she goes there's free complimentary
breakfast she goes it's a continental
breakfast which goes we also have hot
food
because of kovid uh we don't have the
hot food out but she goes don't worry
about
it uh when uh cove is over we have eggs
and bacon and
bagels and locks she does that for no
one else by the way and it's like
they're slinging really expensive
apartments it's just hilarious that the
sales point is bagels she's like we got
locks and bagels and eggs you like that
you fat [ __ ] don't you
you don't have to see the gym right
because we don't want you dying in it
so we have big bowls of eggs we have a
butler service they'll bring the eggs
right up to your apartment
shove them down your fat gullet and
you're like okay
ben by the way they're like you want to
see the gym you want to see the lap pool
with me they're like here's a nice room
where you can sit
here's a theater we have a screening
room so you can sit here
and it's you can reserve it and just sit
in here alone so you don't have to be
outside with other good looking people
we know that makes you nervous so you
could just lock yourself in our
screening room for three hours and cry
how about that fatty we've rented to
pigs like you before we know what
amenities you really want
she the first thing they started telling
me about you because you have a butler
service that brings the food
to the unit this is literally the first
thing out of her mouth she goes
we have a butler service so the food
comes in
and then the food goes to the butler
service and then the butler server
brings it up to the unit
so you don't have to do anything you
don't have to leave your uh
unit and have everyone see you
storming downstairs like an angry
rhinoceros
trying to find out where the pokeball is
they just put it
they open the door and they just shove
it right at ya
she didn't she focused on like the
health center for literally one minute
she's like here outside here are our
chairs here's the seating area you like
sitting don't you
so then we're walking around she's
showing us the units and some of them
are nice but some of them are whatever i
mean is their apartments right
every modern new apartment is the same
thing every single one
and if you want to read the best um
criticism of architecture and urban
planning
that is out there right now a.a gill
who is a travel writer uh for the sunday
times of london and vanity fair
scottish guy who wrote some of the best
articles on steak
on cities on travel he was politically
incorrect
um you know like i think he said once
he's like korean is this
is this year's must-have asian and you
know like he just said things like that
but he was a brilliant writer and he
wrote one of my favorite articles ever
written is called condos
of the living dead and it is great and
it is
really about the new
high-end and i'd never been in one i
mean i've lived in new york city for
years
i had really really never been in like a
high-end
apartment building and i'd never had the
sales uh
uh team the the woman the hot chick
lead you around the apartment and show
you all the amenities
and i wanted to do it and one of the
reasons i wanted to do it is because i
love that article condos of the living
dead
and he talks about it and i mean it's
just so
good i mean do you have an option i do
oh you have it i read some of it
i mean it's it's one of those articles
that is so
pitch perfect when they talk about the
people that sell you
um you know these apartments and
everything like that i want to find
the part of it that i really like
and uh again i would just recommend that
you read it
but it's so funny and he talks about how
all this is about lifestyle which is the
word that they all talk about right
it's all about lifestyle and uh and he
talks about it and he
really some of these lines that really
really get me
here about these things
sales people haunt the empty apartment
spinning a life
made of brushed steel and 12 shades of
indian marble
after a time the repetition of this
lifestyle blends all the apartments into
one apartment
they all have minute hundred thousand
dollar kitchens that no one will ever
toast more than a bagel in
which is just as well because there's
nowhere to sit and eat anyway there are
hardly any dining rooms even living
rooms
no new new york style has a great room a
place to plug in your laptop
prop up your flat screen suck starbucks
and serve soapy asian babes
the bedrooms are for solitary fear
and chemical unconsciousness they seem
to contain just enough oxygen for a
single night's sleep
these apartments don't have space for a
family or dogs with hair
or lives that involve more than the
passive absorbing
of electronic stimuli and emails
so that's really the brilliance
of the article you've got to read the
[ __ ] article but this chick comes out
and she's hot
persian good-looking not an extra ounce
of fat on her
black hair decent skin really good skin
something going on on the forehead i
wasn't completely in love with
but it is what it is they're an oily
people persians are they not i don't
really know
but ben was like whoa like ben you know
was a christian boy with a wife so he
doesn't
really you know but he noticed how
attractive she was in
like a boyish way he kind of know i mean
she was an attractive woman the high
heels the clicking and the clacking yeah
it was very
very very very hot ben was like fighting
with himself he's like wow this is
i'm having thoughts that jesus doesn't
like
but this woman was hot now of course i
don't give a [ __ ]
doesn't matter to me if she pulled out a
big hog it would have been interesting
like if she sat on one of these
countertops and started jerking like a
fat eight-inch [ __ ]
i would have been like this is kind of
interesting and then she could have
serviced both me and ben
in different ways in one of the
apartments who would have been great
but she didn't do that we're walking
around we're looking at these apartments
and listen if you know anything about
ten thousand santa monica there's really
only one question i wanna ask
and the question is where did steve bing
jump from steve being friends with bill
clinton
ron berkel used to hang out with them
hollywood what was he screenwriter
producer screenwriter a producer
yeah he hung out with rob lowe and all
those guys he hung out with all those
guys roblox also lives
at 10 000 santa monica and steve bing
jumped to his death because he was broke
who knows or because maybe he called
bill clinton he's like we've done a lot
of bad things and i just got to get some
of them off my chest yeah you know bill
clinton made a phone call he's like
hey man this is just not the same steve
we knew and that's probably the code in
those circles for like he needs to go
yeah it's just not the same steve we
knew man steve calls him crying
going like i can't believe the things
we've done we're going to burn in hell
for it
i just got to get him off my chest and
he's like no now don't worry about it
steve listen
you're a good man you go to bed and you
know
and this sales [ __ ] this hot sales
[ __ ] probably [ __ ] turned off the
cameras and let the [ __ ] mossad in
there to throw him off the balcony
and she'll do the same thing for me but
i said to her i said can we ask you an
inappropriate question she's like of
course you can
i i think she was she might have been
down a [ __ ]
she was down the [ __ ] ben she would have
let me watch
she would have said listen pig you sit
in the corner of the room
and diddle yourself while this man [ __ ]
me
she would have absolutely been into that
she would have said we know what you're
gonna get out of this you sit in the
corner
and watch him [ __ ] beat up my [ __ ]
on this [ __ ] tiny little kitchen
island
with a great view everybody can come now
don't touch me pig
but everyone can come and then rent the
apartment
but of course i wasn't pushing that i
just wanted to know where steve bing
jumped i said
and she goes oh i'm not going to tell
you that and i said okay and she goes do
you really want to know i said yes she
goes
the unit you're in right now the unit
she was showing us on the 27th floor
is where steve bing jumped off the
juliet balcony which means
you can't put furniture on it right but
you can just stand on it
look outside and jump and
she's like this unit right now and i'm
like really and she goes yep
and i was like [ __ ] and i looked at her
and i said well
at least he got a view of the pacific
while he was doing it and she looked at
me and without missing a beat she said
you can also see all of downtown
she was just perfect absolutely
perfect you can also see all
of downtown not missing a beach because
yes steve was a good guy i said yeah
people have problems you know so we're
standing there in steve bing's apartment
and by the way that is how [ __ ]
steve bing was at the end of his life he
lost all this money and i didn't realize
it
he lost so much money that some
podcaster might rent his apartment
or is at least thinking about it what a
nightmare for steve bing
how bad was it the last indignity that a
podcaster would rent that apartment and
maybe i would kill myself in the exact
same way
what if i took that apartment and killed
myself in the exact
same way that steve bing did then it
would just be the apartment where
everybody dies
we call this the suicide suite
tim dillon threw himself off it before
that it was steve bing
ben's so funny ben says she's such an
interesting kid he goes maybe we could
you know maybe you could
try to get some money off if you know
you bring up the bing thing and i'm like
yeah they'll they'll rent it to just
some chinese person who has no idea who
he is
or they'll rent it to the guy that
killed him she'll look at me and she'll
be like will you shut the [ __ ]
up i'll rent it to the guy that killed
him she's like i pushed him
wouldn't that be great if she looked at
me and i said yeah man people have
mental problems because i pushed him
because there was a hundred grand there
was a there was a bag
of a hundred thousand dollars in my car
that day i knew what i had to do there
was a seven minute span of time the
security cameras were off
and i went up there i took my top off i
said steve
i want to [ __ ] and he said yeah and i
said yeah [ __ ] me up against the
right up against the julia balcony out
the window and then
she just turned around and pushed him
off somehow
imagine she hears this like we go back
in
she's like so uh someone i know is a
member of your
patreon service and uh you did an
episode saying that i killed steve bing
i
[ __ ] steve bing to death off the
balcony and i'll go
well this is how i this is how i make a
living and i
you did tell me all about the
continental breakfast did you not
what did you think of the building i
mean it's a nice building beautiful
building
beautiful building um we did confirm it
is
it is steve bing's room though because
he did jump from the 27th floor by the
way
so that is that is a hundred percent
true
fingerling but they do everything what
if i didn't stop saying that i was like
we they do everything for you they
literally will wash your car
they'll drive you to the airport they'll
give you a free car if it's in a three
mile
and they will turn off the security
cameras and let the massage kill you
she goes you don't even have to kill
yourself we will literally throw you off
the balcony
of your building at the behest of a
crime family like the clintons
don't worry about it don't worry about
it one phone call you're out of here
supposedly his girlfriend had killed
herself a year before and then
the quarantine was getting to him back
in june that's that's what i've been
i've been reading about it a lot today
so it's a combination of he was broke
the quarantine was getting to him
he was coming off the ant on the
anniversary of his girlfriend overdosing
on xanax she got from his palm springs
home
yeah well these people by the way a lot
of these people
are living lives and they're in the [ __ ]
that you don't know what they're doing
and you don't know why people are are
odin or they're killing themselves or
maybe it's just because
if you have that kind of money
everything sucks
maybe that's it maybe he just secretly
wants to storm the capital like
maybe maybe that's what all these rich
people want when they kill themselves
they're like
i just want to get sucked into something
that makes me want to storm the capitol
i don't know maybe they're just like i
want to [ __ ]
you know they're like i'm sick of being
the target of q anon i want to be in
queueing on
i don't know he had a career he had a
run in hollywood
what did he do tell the people what he
did by the way this is our r.i.p steve
bing episode
it will be titled r.i.p steve bing
how great would it be if i rent the
apartment and steve bing just appears
every night to me
and he's like listen you fat [ __ ] you
know where the window is
we're both kidding ourselves if you
think you're going to be here more than
two months
um so he wrote uh kangaroo jack
uh that was his like solo thing he wrote
well that was a stunning uh
it was a total failure and an
embarrassment was it
he should have been thrown off the
[ __ ] balcony for that
the last thing he did oh so he how great
would it be if they were just like this
is for kangaroo jack
and then throw him off this is for
kangaroo jack
um so he also he co-wrote conair
which that's impressive that's a good
it's a great movie man
the last thing on air so the last thing
he did
is where the convicts take over the
plane
oh wow right yeah yeah interesting
interesting why'd you say wow
well there's a connection there right
well
conair let's just go with it right
conair
the convicts take over the plane 9 11.
the terrorists take over the plan
see this is if i was a q anon guy that's
all i'd have to say
that's what's how lazy conspiracies are
right now all you would have to say is
that
and people would just start nodding and
go [ __ ] yeah man this super chat money
just starts coming in like
did you start throwing you the cash i'm
like i made that connection
i made that connection for you pay me
um so the film that he had produced and
flopped was the
uh i think most recently the rules don't
apply it's the hughes biopic
directed by warren beatty betty beatty
man get it right warm baby like he's a
[ __ ] legend sorry
stick tracy [ __ ] i think he used
to [ __ ] madonna warren beatty
really yeah so he used to roll around
with like james kahn and rob lowe in the
80s he was part of the they called him
the rag tag
yeah whatever it was things were good
yeah thank you were good
good house in bel air things were good
news hanging out bill clinton
mick jagger and ron berkel and they used
to have a plane called air [ __ ] one yeah
where they would take people on it and
[ __ ] them
and i'm sure everybody on that plane had
their license checked
so steve bing hollywood producer
screenwriter
i think he was good friends with tom
hanks too he threw a hundred million
into polar express uh oh
sorry uh-oh i don't know good friends
with tom hanks
who knows i don't know
isaac cappy said a thing about tom hanks
right
and by the way like i said if it was all
true folks
wouldn't shock me wouldn't move
would not like i i haven't seen any
evidence that is true
but if it came out that it was true that
tom hanks was part of some
hollywood super secret pedophile cult i
would be
i would go like this and go ha ha well
interesting wouldn't shock me
after doing the who took johnny episodes
and talking to nick bryant nothing would
shock me
i just still nothing shocking you
doesn't mean that you just run out there
without any evidence
and accuse people of literally the most
horrible and heinous activity on earth
uh uh because it somehow helps donald
trump
mean it's the craziest way it's the
craziest reason to free the children
right because it helps donald trump by
the way it's the crit
how many of these people are going to
just not care about kids after this
oh yeah oh after trump's out they're not
going to care about kids anymore they're
gonna be like well i hope those kids are
free now because i don't give a [ __ ]
they go if i can't if i can't i can't
bash this over the head of liberals
if i can't own the libs with saving kids
i ain't into it
going to save and kids just just to get
the other side back
they're just lifting the kids out of the
tunnels now you realize why we're doing
this right
you realize where we're doing this good
it's so we can deregulate
the energy markets for exxon
we need enough political clout so that
donald trump
can go deregulate energy markets that's
why we're pulling out of these tunnels
we actually didn't give that much of a
[ __ ]
before and we won't after
but i want to go in heavy to roblox
tomorrow it's going to be a massive what
is your version going in heavy you're
getting paid too much
like 500 bucks men's paid 30 a month for
this show
what if i didn't pay you any money like
the patreon was like so much money and i
just didn't pay you any money
no matter what i pay him it's never
enough the wife goes you know it's not
enough ben
i'm gonna give them a real good
christmas i my goal
is to have a wedding coming up and uh
where are you doing it like a taco truck
right
no in green uh green hall outside austin
don't tell people where it is
people show up what do you what are you
serving you're serving like baked beans
and
sausage links hot links we're gonna have
uh the the the
blue build cherry vanilla as dessert
that is good
uh we're gonna do some jalapeno poppers
from a local restaurant we're gonna do
barbecue we're gonna do brisket we're
gonna
dance uh it's it's very small i'll ask
katie if there's room for a dad yeah
i'm sure you well um
um so what do you have and you have a
blue bell ice cream
we're gonna have british what's the main
course do we have get a mini course
barbecue what's the
oh nice what's the cocktail hour you get
a little shrimp cocktail
we'll do some you know i'm sure we'll
have wine and beer we're not going to do
liquor but uh
wine and you know probably shiner bach
lone star texas beer
for the people okay how many people are
coming
about 60. wow yeah pretty small kind of
that's kind of big is it who did you
invite devon and ida
uh i mean we i told them that i would
invite them but i didn't want them to
spend the money on a plane ticket
because i knew they'd be you know put
out on the whole thing
right they're traveling you're the point
they have to fly people into the wedding
that's if i got married to i'd have to
panic
i have to fly my family in cause baby
they have to fly them into the wedding
i'll fly him into a to a [ __ ] it
won't be a wedding
i just want to get married so i could
make a mess of it
like i would love to have a wedding just
so i could relapse on drugs
and drinking an hour before and
that's kind of funny if you think about
doing this as a bit
no i know it would it would ruin your
life maybe but it'd be a great bit to
relapse an hour before
and just be drunk and just be like
screaming at your
do you love me do you really love
me and then you look out at the people
you go [ __ ] all these people
they don't matter do you love me
like that's what i want to do i want to
get real like sauced up
before i make it marry someone
and then i go do you love me do you look
at me
look at me right now
and i too the priest is going well i
don't know if i'd have a priest right
i'd probably get a priest those
pedophiles
he'll marry a couple of [ __ ] i go hey
will you shut the [ __ ] up like the
priest is like
to having to hold and go hey you shut
the [ __ ] up for a minute
and i grab the person and go do you
[ __ ] love me
um that's that's what now is there going
to be speeches or did you have the best
man like how does it work
uh so we're doing it a little bit
different because me and katie are
already officially married and we had to
change some things around
right so we're not doing like the actual
boring church pews
we're doing something totally different
okay but but people can give speeches
and we'll be dancing and stuff but we're
not doing like the formal like at the
altar
you may now kiss the bride type who's
gonna give a speech
uh i'm my brother we'll give you a
speech wow nice if he you know
he comes and now
who else will give a talk um uh katie's
uncle i'm sure katie's dad will as well
and dude i hope it's full cue do you
want to give a speech at the wedding i
mean i don't know i mean
i mean do you have a budget wait did you
say you hope it's full
yeah full kill i hope it's like three
senses about you and katie and then he
starts to go like
yeah her father goes like listen
uh you know we all know trump is still
the president
you know the jew media can say whatever
they want i'll just stand up with the
blue by eating bluebell smoking butts
going
you tell him tell him he goes they can
say whatever they want but the reality
is
we're in a war we're in a war right now
and i'm happy that you two are married
because you're going to need a good
partner when you're fighting a war
against satan i'm if this is not that
wedding ben i'll leave
i want this wedding to be a straight-up
christian like like hellscape i want to
be called a [ __ ]
and and i want them to say
the only reason you're allowed here is
because you had candace owens on the
show
and uh and uh if this is not that i will
be so disappointed
by the way she's getting a late night uh
television show yeah on the daily wire
probably be funnier than kimmel's so
it'd be interesting i'm not going to
speak at the wedding because it's it's
weird when
someone who is like a guy like me talks
at a wedding like i
have you given a speech at a wedding
i've never given a speech i mean
it's not it's a real i would just get
out
do you want me to give the speech i will
give it to the wedding sure go ahead
here's the speech let's give it away
that's the wedding
okay uh thank thank you all
for being here and celebrating the love
of of bannon
and catherine katie katie katie
um i met ben and katie a few years ago
and i used them i lived in the small
room of their house
i showered there the water bill went up
it was very tough um ben wasn't working
and katie was working and no one really
had any money and
me and ben smoked cigarettes all night
and watched alex jones and katie was
very worried about the direction of
where this was heading and i and i
and i i understand that and i get it and
i i still believe that i have taken
advantage of that
to a degree that is unconscionable every
night i lay in my bed
and i say to myself you're a scumbag for
what you did
to this couple truly and the fact that
they withstood
my torment my selfishness uh
is shocking to me that they were able to
weather the storm that was uh
tim dillon uh i want to apologize to
them publicly
for everything i have done and continue
to do
um i yelled at ben once when he was late
and i'm sorry about that it was uh
very sad to do
to raise my voice to him it was it was
not right when he
showed up at a when i had to take a uh
a car uh he had to bring his car so i
could take a road test and he said it
was on e and then i shouldn't worry
about it and
to just tell the instructor of the road
tested it's okay we have 90 miles left
which is the most irresponsible thing
you could do i probably would have been
failed right off the bat
but that's okay i and then i yelled at
him and i said what did i say to you
that day
um you're gonna like bash my skull i
said i was gonna bash his skull
and i called him a drunk which is ironic
because he was two years sober
but i was hitting the the thing in the
car and i i
scared him a little bit but that's what
i do i'm scary
and mean i'm a scary pig
who comes in and ruins everybody's life
and the fact that they're even having
this wedding right now
after everything i've put these two
through is uh
amazing to me so again i just want
everyone to raise their glass
um to ben and katie who
have made it through the
disease the real pandemic which is tim
dillon
um i know every day and every moment
they both wish i died
and just hope that they're in my will so
that they can spend my money
while i die which is the best case
scenario for everybody
so with that being said i've got to go
back
to my blue bell ice cream while i sit
here at this wedding alone
and try to think of reasons not to kill
myself on the dance floor which we don't
have because of covet or jesus or
whoever
um and i'm going to listen to the fiddle
band
with ben's brother as we both sit here
lonely and have a seventh helping of
barbecue
and [ __ ] in the chairs and uh basically
stare at everyone else who has love in
their life
thank you everyone please subscribe to
our patreon
and uh please get an nft of me killing
myself
which ben will be shooting if he has the
time
i'm sure they'll take a nine month
honeymoon after this
and if i call them and ask them what's
going on
they'll be like who is it again oh it's
that terrorist he wants me to do some
work
so again uh i want to thank both of them
they're such
interesting people both of them uh i
love talking to them about the things
that happened
in their neighborhood or someone who
might have gotten shot that day
or a dog that was lost that they found
um that's
very illuminating to me the types of
discussions that i've been uh privileged
to have with both of them at tables
about uh avocado toast and
someone who may have been shot or it
might have been a firework
so again thank you everyone i will be
doing i'll have an autograph booth later
if you want to come and
take a photo with the pig and you can
show it
to all the people who live in sewer
taxes or wherever the hell
you people come from god bless you good
night
i mean i would do something that was
lovely no i would really say i would
really say
um wouldn't it be great if i just stood
up and i went
you know i
made this event happen truly
i mean i did it they fell in love but
this is it's all mine everything you're
eating
take that brisket out of your mouth this
is my
words that have made this happen okay
this entire wedding was paid for by
me so it's my way
it's
okay now i don't have anyone to marry
but make no goddamn mistake about it
it's as much my wedding as is their
wedding
so i would like to recite the vows
after they do because it's my day
any time to get the [ __ ] out it's my day
okay i just bring up some twink then i
just met some 20 year old twig i go
we're getting married right now
but it'll be i'm excited for it
i'm excited for it i and i'm i you know
i wasn't going to go to your last
wedding because i don't we didn't even
like each other at that point
remember your last wedding that i wasn't
going to go to i remember
that i said i was on the road but i
don't think i was i think you actually
were
on the road i think i might have been on
the road yeah i think we're having a
rough patch
yeah we were going we had a couple rough
uh like three weeks
what was it do you remember um
i can't remember the exact specifics of
it i remember it was when we
started doing the dark studio right
around that time when i was building
that out
but you know i don't do like a lunatic
so i can't remember the exact details
i don't remember the details either but
i was like hey man i can't be involved
but good luck
yeah and then you didn't want me there
anyway you and i probably didn't want me
there
it's not true that's true um i can't i
imagine that i'm not wanted at this one
either
i i did receive an invitation though
which i think is nice yes you did
i did i died that's sweet but my goal
here's what my goal is
is to give them a present that is so
nice
that they both feel horrible
like my goal is to give them a present
that it's
so nice that they both really feel
bad and it
it it asserts my dominance over them
the way an old billionaire from a
stephen king novel who has like the
whole town in his grips
you know like you know they're like mr
has owned this town since the early days
of you know
like i i want to come in and just give
you guys a present
that's so over the top that
i just want you both to know
that it's my day
you know what i mean it's not your day
it's my day
i may tell everyone what i give you i
may get up and go
let me tell you what let me what i gave
these two schmucks
these two people here's what i gave them
i'm gonna give you a really nice present
you don't even know what it is
i'm gonna give you a very nice present
oh really wow no i mean
it's gonna be very it's gonna be like
nicer than
i i think it'll be the best present you
got you fire me at the wedding
i'm gonna fire you from the show and i'm
gonna bring lisa
where is lisa by the way we keep doing
like a running joke about lisa is that
mean or not
is he doing okay he has a he has a
podcast and a patreon i don't want to
keep doing this joke if he's like
homeless or something go support lisa
guys go support leaders but i don't know
where he is so
sometimes you do jokes about people and
then you find out they're in a coma and
you go i gotta stop
i gotta stop doing that that's not nice
to do
he fell asleep on his live stream on his
twitch that's hilarious
you should keep doing that every podcast
you should just fall asleep on a live
stream
i would watch that i don't want to watch
anything and if lisa
goes i will fall asleep at some point
during this live stream
i'd absolutely watch it
comp should do the same thing but i'm
excited about this wedding man
and what what what time is it is it like
six hours
no no no it's gonna be quick and
painless we don't want it to be a
boring long wedding we want it in and
out in and out
get the what get some drinks get out
what if i get married the same day
oh my god and i hold a wedding
that what if i married jake paul on the
same day
in in miami and invite all of your
friends
who which friend are you inviting other
than travie uh debbie boobie's coming
um jake is coming who you met jake he
lives in austin
is he the guy that we had on to talk
about the dark web yeah he's the dark
web guy from old episodes that's good
um i'm trying to think who else uh john
key a friend of mine from abilene
and that's about it a lot of people
can't make it because of covid or
that's all fake yeah what are they
talking about it can't make us a carving
a lot of people just not in their budget
to travel all the way to texas and back
and i totally get it i haven't gone to
weddings for that for that reason too
cause you're out like a grand for like
the tickets for you and your wife and
then the hotel and then
i really have not been invited to a lot
of weddings it kind of saddens me
i've got one wedding i went to what to
my friend tina's sister's wedding i
didn't bring a present
i the guy hates she married some tow
truck guy
and he hates me because i didn't bring a
present i just showed up did they say
something i just showed up by he was at
russo's on the bay of brooklyn
i just showed up by dinner and left i
didn't really stick
oh my god
i dinner i smoked a few butts with the
staff of russo's in the back and i just
got out of there
by the way i don't even know if i had to
sit down dinner russo's on the bed is a
great a cocktail hour it's like
the little lamb chops fresh tomato and
mutts i think i went to that
for about two hours and then i left
and i
i've not been invited to a lot of
weddings oh man
i went to my friend joe's wedding the
mortgage guy i went to his wedding i
just have not gone to a lot of weddings
yeah me neither haven't been invited
never been a bachelor or best man or
anything
i've never been a best man i've never
been
you you'll you'll be you would be my
best man if i got it
would you get would you be best man at a
gay wedding absolutely i would
well you don't know who i'm married
you want me to finish yeah would you be
the best man at a wedding with me and
richard spencer
let me finish i've never been a best man
dude i've never been like part of the
wet like i just went into comedy and
every
everybody's a loser nobody gets married
in this the roommates i had when i first
started comedy got married
in a basketball gymnasium in staten
island it was like an embarrassment
and it like you know they had like hero
sandwiches and stuff i mean it was an
embarrassment
you know but i i you know i've never
been like the guy that people say
oh this guy should be our best because
i'm just not close with a lot of people
i just fell out a lot
my friend joe got married in new orleans
but i was headlining a room i can't do i
was like i can't do it
i've worked years to get into headline
and this was like a room that
somebody cancelled they threw me in last
minute which he understood
i was also sober i just want to go to a
wedding in new orleans everybody getting
bombed
totally drink it absinthe
some people go to a ton of weddings i
i've never been to like my family's
wedding like my cousins or
aunts my cousins aren't getting married
during dope they're on heroin
thank god thank god imagine you had it
going to their weddings
thank christ thank god they're on heroin
they found something they love
it's not bothered they don't bother
anybody let them live
i mean yeah no one in my family got
married i'm the most successful cousin
and i'm a gay
ex-cocaine addict uh clown
and i'm the most successful like old
none of them figured anything out really
i mean some of them did they bounce
around some of them are okay i guess
but i'm excited for it it's happening in
april
i mean it's gonna be it's gonna be
interesting to see like your family i've
never met your family
they like know who i am i guess my mom's
a fan of the show yeah they know who i
am
but i've never met any of them um
[Music]
should i bring chevron is my plus one
which i'm sure i don't even get but no
you do you do you should i bring uh you
know who christopher
just interviewed the [ __ ] tt
who's sucked off who's sucked off son of
sam in prison
wait is that you yeah stefano just did
one of the greatest interviews in
podcast
and he tt his his girl
jasmine is like her aunt or uncle or
whatever i don't know
and she went to prison with she was like
imprisoned with tupac
and she sucked off son of sam so can i
bring
bring titi we'll talk about sucking off
son of sam
that's fine yeah ben's parents are so
christian
i'll just i'll let her give a speech
let me give some of my speech to tt and
she's like
listen i sucked oh son of sam in prison
all right where's the blue bell ice
cream everybody let's get out to
bluebell
i mean i'm just happy to meet everybody
finally
n or noah or any of those guys come you
didn't really talk to them that much
i didn't invite any of those guys yeah
you don't talk to that much time to move
on
time to tighten up the circle as beanie
siegel said tighten up the circle before
they hurt you
beanie siegel tighten up the circle
before they hurt you
you know devin and i are coming you got
to pay them huh you got to pay them you
gotta
slide them down and put them up
they'll be putting the food in a bag
they'll be putting a barbecue in a
plastic bag
and walking out with it they're trying
to they'll try to resell it
they'll try to sell it on etsy authentic
texas barbecue
yeah they'll sell it they'll be
reselling brisket
they'll be on clubhouse figuring out how
to resell brisket
i mean they should come down for it
though they might be fun
oh yeah i told them i was like i don't
want to subject you to having to come
but you are invited but what did they
say
they're like oh no we we get it like
thank you for letting us not have to
be feel like we have to come you know
mean when's the last time devons got on
a plane or left echo park like at all
yeah they don't they don't leave
no but yeah i like the way they said
they go thank we appreciate you
not making us feel obligated to show
exactly thank you
you good thanks a lot but could you send
us food
but if there's any leftovers can you
send them in the mail
by the way just send them in the mail if
there's any leftovers
this dhl has some pulled pork
if you don't mind they should come i may
pay them to get them down there yeah
let's bring them down i may fly them
down and i'm flying on tt
what's the what's the barge is it a big
budget what's the budge
is it like 800 000 yeah yeah
it's it's the size of sal volcano's
wedding
i'm i'm wondering what the budget is
maybe i should pay for the wedding
weddings by the way i was probably gonna
give you more money than the wedding
i offered to pay for the wedding it's
like eighteen hundred dollars like wait
excuse me
like yeah it's a van of barbecue food in
a field i'm like oh
i had no idea what are you gonna wear do
you wear a cowboy hat and [ __ ]
no but maybe i should actually it's not
a bad idea
is katie gonna wear white yeah she has a
wedding dress picked out of course i
haven't seen it but
what if if i come in an outfit
that distracts from both of you will you
be angry
no like if i come that's like one of you
know
the beginning of the wizard of oz all
the people that are walking around yeah
yeah
can i announce my transition you know
amy schumer announced her pregnancy at
another comic's wedding to just take the
shine right out of her way yeah yeah
yeah
to shine right at somebody else i want
to announce something your wedding i
gotta want to go i'm transitioning
what if i pulled i showed everyone my
[ __ ] what if i got a [ __ ] if i had my
penis made into a [ __ ]
and i showed everyone my [ __ ] lips i go
look at my [ __ ]
i have a [ __ ] now and i want to show
everyone my [ __ ]
my penis was inverted have i described
it
i stood up and i go i love ben and katie
and i feel so comfortable with everyone
here i want to
tell you my penis was split in half and
inverted
and made into a [ __ ] four days ago
and i finally got the bandages off now
my my my shaft has been split and turned
into two lips of a puss
and i want to show everyone right now i
just drive with my [ __ ]
and people are like oh my god
katie's father's like that's purdy
that's a pretty [ __ ]
i'm like thank you he's like that's
a real purty [ __ ]
i just wanna i just wanna go and
cause such a scene
dude i'm going
i'm going with tt i'm going okay okay
i'm going with the training who blew son
of sam i'm telling you
that distefano just interviewed i'm
paying her 20 000
and thank you patreon for the ability to
do that i'm going to pay tt
to come to the wedding and tell the
story about sucking off son of sam
in front of your christian parents
and if that if your wife doesn't like me
then so be it
if she doesn't see the humor in that
then then so be it
and i don't know why you would marry her
it's crazy to me
that she would not see the humor in that
run that by her tomorrow call her and go
okay tim is going to fly
tt who was just
the transgender woman christie stefano
interviewed
she sucked off son of sam in prison and
tim thinks it'd be great
to have her talk about that at the
wedding
i mean i don't is this a problem i run
it by her i mean
i don't see the problem
i want tt to officiate my wedding what's
her name
look her up even though he can't play it
get this woman's name she's like a
gangster it's titi
i don't know just it's stefano's latest
episode
i forget
mr6 didn't kill princess joyanna at all
my daughter's lying is nobody racist in
the royal family
the continent of india needed to be
civilized
oh tt jerry tt jerry yeah
she's come to the wedding oh tt jerry's
comfortable
tt jerry there's not much there's like
nothing about her except for chris's
episode
with her yeah well yeah she doesn't have
a lot going on but that's okay
we're about to change that she's about
to go to your wedding and make a big
splash
what if she sucked off katie's dad
she's like i sucked off that man
and i also stuck to a son of stamp
chris was like did you meet any
celebrities in prison she goes yeah i
sucked off son of sam
it's crazy is it crazy or is it
beautiful
and dessert is what is it bluebell ice
cream and cobbler the cherry vanilla
yeah we're gonna do cobbler yeah what
kind of cobbler
peach ooh yeah peach
are you a franklin barbecue we might do
franklin's i'm gonna have to check with
katie i forget the two places we were
between
yeah it's very interesting not not a
salt uh whatever that was
do you know you want to hear my wedding
yeah yeah it's on little st james
okay that's number one so it's an
international waters
okay okay do you know who is the claret
the cleric is a is the guy
from he's that guy that we watch for me
we used to watch an islamic
fundamentalist in brooklyn who's like
had a lot of personality
i forget he was like he goes i like
being on first class
he just talks about death to america but
he goes because i like
traveling first class i think it's good
he's in some like
real crazy mosque in brooklyn where he
goes i i like i like
nice things the crowds get getting with
it he goes i like flying first class i
don't know about you
they're just waiting to hear what they
should blow up because i i don't know
about you but i like
i like getting on in the play in the
first class
so he's going to be the cleric okay
um my best man
is going to be tt jerry
best woman flower girl okay
um
i don't know man it's so interesting to
watch you're the closest friend i've
ever had that's like gotten married
where like i'm actually
i felt bad i didn't get a gift for that
other wedding but i didn't give a [ __ ]
about that
no one ever showed up for a dinner yeah
what do i do
a guy is a tow truck business did you
say hi to them at least and congrats i
don't think i did
i think i did once i think i did once
i think i said gay congrats and then i
just kept walking
rolling yeah i was just walking around
eating lamb chops
and then i left i left like two hours in
people texting me like where'd you go i
said oh i was if it's over
i didn't go to the church salvakana's
wedding we didn't i didn't show up for
the church the
church and showed her for the food yeah
yeah that's the most recent i went to
mike lawrence's wedding he was a
comedian that was done in like a
backyard though his mom cooked but the
food was very good
um
um but yeah this will be kind of an
amazing
like thing you know you're like the
version like i don't have a brother so
you're like a brother
it's like watching your brother get
married that you like a lot of people
hate
their siblings so i didn't realize that
i was wanted like siblings and i
realized most people just hate their
siblings
absolutely it's hilarious i had no idea
every siblings i've ever met i'm like
you talk to your brother a lot they
cannot really i'm like interesting
you know let's think about just lane
maxwell's family it's like they were
close
maybe there's something to that you know
what i mean
that's the thing it's like people talk a
lot of [ __ ] like oh
you know whatever dylan and ronan farrow
seem to be close
it's true this is true right
i don't know
i want to see tt jerry on rogan you
started off on the channel
[ __ ] crazy enough i sucked out son of
sam joe
she sucked off like a murderer like like
a satanic serial killer
and she's talking about it at your
wedding this is teaching jerry
she's sucked off i'll tell people that
on the buffet line too
i go tt's my date she sucked off son of
sam in prison